[Musique]
son nom est sur toutes les lèvres dans
tous les esprits
si la fontaine symbole de ces filles
autochtones qui disparaissent le long du
chemin ou dans une rivière
symbole de la justice non rendu est ce
que c'est encore sécuritaire de marcher
dans la rue demande c'est autochtone de
17 ans ici je me fais tuer est-ce qu'on
va souciés de moi il n'y en a pas
d'égalité de justice pour nous ajoute sa
grand mère les experts le reconnaissent
la preuve présentée par la couronne pour
incriminer raymond cormier était très
mince et se sont mis un peu une pression
sur les épaules d'arriver avec des
résultats concrets pour apaiser la
population autochtone et je pense qu'on
a monté un peu trop d'espoirs dans un
dossier faible comme ça mais pour les
autochtones difficile de ne pas voir ce
verdict comme un autre échec il ya deux
semaines en saskatchewan
un homme blanc a été acquitté du meurtre
de cotone bauchi un jeune cris cette
organisatrice crois que c'est bien plus
que le système judiciaire qu'il faut
changer notamment la prise en charge des
enfants autochtones par les services
sociaux
au moment de sa mort tina fontaine
n'était plus dans sa famille mais sous
la responsabilité de l'état l'état qui
l'avait placé dans une chambre d'hôtel
faute de place ailleurs
on ne fait plus haut maintenant explique
la protectrice des enfants du manitoba
mais c'est sûr qu'il y encore beaucoup
de travail à faire si la mort de tina
fontaine avait créé une onde de choc et
contribuer à l'ouverture d'une enquête
nationale
ce verdict pourrait aussi servir de
catalyseur les autochtones veulent des
changements profonds et leur colère est
loin de s'estomper
et si laurence martin radio canada à
winnipeg